all right what's more likely coming out
of the nfc north the vikings and the
lions specifically
what's more likely kirk cousins plays
the next two seasons with the vikings
or is traded chris i'm gonna say he
plays the next two seasons with the
minnesota vikings i am
you know again we've we've hit a few of
these guys lately
i know you know derek carr and and
everybody else but he's a
he's a fringe top 10 quarterback and he
makes plays for your offense it's just
tell me better options out there listen
i know if you can trade and get to sean
watson cool
at russell wilson great but i mean i
don't think that's realistic
so kirk cousins you can win with so i
think he's going to stay there the next
two years what do you think there
minnesota unless
i i think he's staying i think he's
staying because
trading him unless you do get some sort
of a superstar level guy that creates a
ton of excitement
and gets ownership to say we understand
that it's going to be difficult to get
the most out of this right away
that secures mike zimmer and rick
spielman for another year i mean i i
hate to be this cynical about it but
i've
been covering the sport for 20 years
there's an element of
what decision is more likely to get me
fired and if you
if you trade kirk cousins and you don't
have a great replacement
you're more likely to get fired after
this year yeah kirk cousins is more
likely to save mike zimmer and rick
spielman
so yeah they're more likely to keep him
even if it means
that they're going to pay him 35 million
next year fully guaranteed and it
becomes fully guaranteed the third day
of the league year march 19 of this year
and cousins told us on pftpm week at the
super bowl he didn't come out and say it
this way
but the message unavoidably was
i'm not doing anything with my contract
i'm not extending it i got two years
left and you know what two years from
now
he's going to hit the open market again
the vikings will not use the franchise
tag on him he'll be entitled to a 44
raise over his cap number as of 2022
because he's been tagged twice before
that stays with you
from team to team and uh uh yeah yeah
that
they're stuck they're stuck and it's
two years left with kirk cousins to go
with the three that he's already played
and he's made it to the playoffs once
in three years so uh i i bet he'll i bet
they'll do it again this year i bet
they'll get back
they won't get very far but it'll be
enough to justify the one more year and
then
and then they make their decisions after
2022 at quarterback chris yeah
i don't i don't think that's you know
crazy thought certainly he's played
again i don't think we viewed last
year's team as a playoff
caliber team to going into the year with
all the changes they made on the
defensive side of the ball trading
stephon diggs but
hey they made it competitive there for a
little while where you went whoa are
they gonna get back in this thing
and of course he was a big part of it
the one thing i'll say about kirk
cousins
he he is a really good down the field
thrower they don't he doesn't throw a
lot of like dink and dunk easy passes i
mean we we watched all year it's
it's play action bootleg whoa there's a
25 yard deep cross to justin jefferson
whoa there's a you know 40-yard post to
adam thielen
uh the degree of difficulty of his
throws
it's pretty up there on the richter
scale and and he delivers more times
than not
i i don't know the richter the richter
scale scale but for the degree of
difficulty but but regardless of that
you know they have a special talent in
justin jefferson and i think as we're in
this period of the off season where
guys are coming up with ideas coaches
are brainstorming
showcase justin jefferson let's not
bring back the randy ratio
vikings fans of the mid 2000's may
remember that failed effort by mike tyse
you don't force it to the guy but let's
use him more aggressively and
extensively than they did last year
what's more likely the viking sign
anthony harris
team safety who was franchise tagged
last year to a long-term deal before
free agency starts or he ends up with
another team i
i think he's gonna end up staying there
i i don't know how you feel it's a tough
one for me i mean
you know there's a lot of they're not in
the best salary cap situation
uh but it is mike zimmer we know how he
values the secondary
harrison smith is you know getting up
there in years
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna say that anthony
harris finds his way back
in minnesota what do you think there
well i think last year was the time to
do it the problem is when you tag him
once
at 11.4 million and you don't work out a
long-term deal and i think the failure
to work out a long-term deal
resulted directly from the fact that the
vikings didn't want to value the
long-term deal based on
the franchise tag number this year i'm
going to do the math real quick
11.44 million last year this year it's
13.7 million to tag him
that's also relevant because that's the
starting point for the long-term deal
i i think that i think that they they uh
may not tag him yeah and uh he may head
to
a place like cleveland where he'd
reunite with kevin stefanski there was
talk last year the browns trading forum
after he was 10. actually
i i'll change my answer i i think you're
right he's not going to be there
i don't they got they got too many other
things they got to worry about
you know they got they got harrison
smith i think as i sat there and talked
that out myself
no they got some young guys in the
secondary they got harrison smith they
got two good middle linebackers
they need defensive line help that's one
thing they need for sure they gotta like
really all across the board so uh i'll
change my mind you're right he's not
gonna be there this year
and he's going to be 30 in october you
know i didn't think of him as the young
guy but he was undrafted i heard pete
say
yeah yeah they coached him up and uh
i think there's a point where you just
have to say we can find another guy that
will coach up again that he's a product
of our system and our coaching and we
can find someone else that's that that
lump of clay we can mold
into the kind of defensive back that we
want all right let's go to detroit real
quickly
what's more likely jared goff proves
this all wrong or he's cut after one
year with the lions
um i mean if you're gonna give me one of
those two choices right there i'm gonna
go cut
after one year i don't think he's gonna
prove this all wrong i don't think
that's gonna happen
i i i don't i've seen enough film
i would be shocked it would have to be a
drastic
change in his game his throwing
you know his his feel in the pocket
and really even for a guy like him who
wasn't asked to do a ton
he wasn't the greatest of managing the
games either so
if you're going to give me one of those
two options i'm going he's cut after
next year
you know the the guaranteed money spills
into 2022.
elements of it sir i'd have to look it
up again i i
it was well over 40 million for two
years and certain elements of it don't
have an
offset obligation so they're they're
they might be stuck
okay they might be stuck it could be
benched after one year could be they
keep them around
could be they do a hot potato trade to
someone else after one year
but uh i i have a feeling that that this
is a two-year commitment
whether he plays well or not in 2021 i
just don't think the lions
are expecting much no anything no your
team this year they're
consciously taking a step back so i
don't think that god's performance
would fairly be judged based on one year
as getting rid of him
that so i think he's there for at least
two years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports